dieter bohlen ist locker ja hallo mein
name ist luca herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einer neuen ford challenge
meine damen und herren vor circa einem
jahr hat sich auf youtube getrennt
verbreitet dass man so tun als sei der
boden lava und ich habe mir gedacht das
machen wir einfach mal in fortnight und
mit mir meine ich mich und chaudry mehr
hallo fortnight battle royale mit luca
da vorne ist mehr freunde und mehr hat
und ich spiele hier duos zusammen er hat
darf immer zwischendurch während des
spielens sagen hey luca der boden des
lava und dann muss ich mich irgendwie
über dem boden bewegen also nicht
irgendwie zwei oder drei plattform hoch
bauen oder auf dem haus gehen oder auf
dem stein klettern oder so und freunde
falls ich es nicht schaffen sollte der
boden des lava umzusetzen also falls
sich noch auf dem boden sein sollte dann
muss ich einen item wegschmeißen was
sich dort unten rechts befindet ihr
müsst wissen dass mehrheit übelster pro
gamer ist so der hat gegen uns gewonnen
ja natürlich das muss jetzt ein bisschen
ressourcen hier wollen weil wenn ich
dann irgendwie hoch bauen muss man
gesagt worden ist hat mich schon normal
ich hätte abgeschossen von irgendwo von
dahinten ersten training bei mir
komplett beschissen mal wieder arbeiten
chillig beide waren zwei deswegen freund
es war auch nicht gelogen dass merck
schon gegen den giro gewonnen hatte das
in jena muss endlich noch im nordwesten
der bundesliga-auftakt ja ok ja gut
jetzt ja hier durch die luft oder hab
ich noch geschafft
hey hast du den ländern ja sehr gut zu
katalog der bundeswehr logo der lose
jetzt sogar die neueste technische
zeitläufe hochhaus krank überraschen
kann
danke herr junker der bundesliga du
bastard als wenn junge duschwanne
treffen haben soll
der junge habe ich ja gar nicht dran
gedacht ist es kaputt schießen kann hat
er nochmal glück gehabt
ja ich weiß nicht ob das heißt aber das
ist ja wenn du etwas apostel sind der
rote punkte sondern mitten unter jenen
steaks braucht er schnell ab meerrettich
spiels nicht zum ersten mal mit der
linken maustaste schieß ich oder mein
wille der rechten okay geht nicht bei
mir kann man seinen eigenen team mates
töten
[Gelächter]
luca der bundesliga boden ein junge ist
habe ich schon mal wenn man's ja hab es
auf den stuhl setze navy vielleicht
laufen müssen um einen gott juni wurden
288 euro
ich bin doch auch mainburg der
bundeslager luca junge fick dich
er wurde aber ich muss eine treppe bauen
[Musik]
was war das man von hier oben sieht die
map so hat klein aus und ist es ja immer
so riesig wie mein schwanz gehe einfach
witzig sterben vorfreude wir sind in
waging gut angekommen sind auf jeden
fall einige kisten am start was haben
wir hier ein sturmgewehr aber nur ein
gewöhnliches ist natürlich richtig
beschissen
wenn man direkt wieder ein bisschen
materialien hier bevor er wieder am
kampf sachen soll zum bus
[Musik]
wer beim bonus level 3
das gibt's ja cars that was hast du
genug jetzt also will kurz was ob du
genug cordes was er wolle ist mit uns
einer hier sieht man muss sich mal
überlegen wie bescheuert dieses spiel
eigentlich ist der bundesliga
[Musik]
fick dich richtig hier aus jedoch aus
der junge herr schild
nein basta okay okay
er schmeißt das werk alter viel spaß
damit
60 60 zwei stücken alter nicht übelsten
luca toni slama ja ich bin auf dem haus
du [ __ ] nein nein ich bin dauern denn
dort kommt kaum junge ja ich dachte du
willst mich da youtube tode kommt der
läuft mit der zone um gott hat mich so
schlich ich sterbe luca bescheißen 1
märz ein
[Musik]
jetzt hab ich da bloß laura ist auch ich
bescheuert alter nein ich denke ich
hätte fest er hofft jetzt lang
ich darf er nicht auf boden gut erstmal
fühle ich mich jetzt hier auf 75 hoch
jetzt nämlich den cirque du wenn ich
einen sap trinkt packte meine dinge ist
auch auf 100
das sind kleine putzte er wohne slava ja
je
die protect x-bow locker der bundesliga
dabei der boden ist luca ja den ich auf
dem boden liegend was macht denn jetzt
nein das hat er mich getötet hat mir
gerade eine freundschaftsanfrage
geschickt ablehnten freunde in dieser
letzten runde machen jetzt mal ein
bisschen action
ihr seht schon das ziel da vorne ist
angepeilt wobei mir im doppel das
kolosseum kolosseums ich habe ich heute
auch nicht bis bald gegen geflogen hat
höher was das denn hier her ich hab noch
munition was ist eigentlich mit boden
des lava wenn ich jetzt schon hier in
dem gebäude drin weil ich bin ja
eigentlich nicht auf dem boden das
schädlich da muss was bauen
okay da wurde das laufen gerät wird sie
selber oder wo mein gott alter schwede
wir würden wir noch lava hatte dass ich
respektiert ich betone unter der treppe
unter der treppe hinter dir mein glück
vorm junge habe ihn mein gott nein ich
hab was gegen chiasso
dabei wies trainer nein wirklich von
lukas kann man dich oh mein gott war gut
ja freunde weil wir so gut waren hängen
wir jetzt noch eine runde dran wird lahm
natürlich wieder enthüllt mehr tag
wieder sagen mit der boden lafer ist wir
sind richtig gut der boden ist
nein hier cup ist so hat er glück gehabt
der bundesliga
awo junges floss wieder ich stehe
einfach wieder der gleichen ecke
aber ich hätte mein gott ich bin auch
sehr kalter schauer lokal mein gott ich
bin mit werden berufen wollte ich dann
geschossen ich habe 22 betone ich kann
mich selbst nicht denn ich hab nicht
mehr ressourcen jetzt mal ein bisschen
action druck gekommen super luca super
wirke bin ich an der stelle wird das
wird jetzt allerdings auch beende meine
damen und herren ich habe mir einfach
mal gedacht wo der boden slava war vor
zehn monaten cool könnte man eigentlich
jetzt mal ein vorteil machen auf jeden
fall keinen dank an wert weil ich die
ganze zeit die kills gemacht habe ihn
die ganze zeit retten musste ist
natürlich klar gewesen wenn euch das
video hier gefallen hat das gerne mal
ein leichter freunde schreibt mir
eventuell weitere form der challenges
und in die kommentare und übrigens
freunde bald werden fordert streams
kommt allerdings doch nicht auf youtube
sondern auftritt weil ich finde ich bin
bei video creator und ich glaube dass
sich youtube er so perfekt hat möchte
qualitätsmäßig & witsch zum stream
nutzen aber das ist ein anderes thema da
werde ich ein paar tagen bisschen
genauer darüber quatschen und jetzt will
ich eigentlich nur sagen